we can save the day we will stand our
ground
we will be brave brave brave we will be
hurt we will matter you matter
you matter vote vote vote vote
vote vote
if you want to alienate almost anyone no
matter their politics just say three
little words
i don't vote your friends will gasp
celebrities will judge you your mother
might still love you but
only grudgingly tell the world that you
care about what happens to it
you have an obligation for america for
america
for america don't you care about america
you not voting changes your life
you are dishonoring your family if you
don't vote
then you're an idiot don't buy the guilt
trip not voting can be an equally
legitimate and moral choice
here are four of the most common myths
used to shame non-voters
we gotta stop thinking one vote we can't
say one vote doesn't matter
your vote matters it affects everything
first things first
you're not going to sway a major
election a single vote has decided
precisely
zero federal races in u.s history and
vanishingly few at the state level
voting is like playing the powerball
punch your ticket or don't your life is
going to stay the same the last
presidential election turned on fewer
than 100
000 votes i know but this is about you
and whether or not you cast your one
vote
it simply won't affect the outcome not
if you live in a swing state
not at the electoral college were
abolished not even if you're in florida
and your chad is hung like a moose
you can't complain if he didn't vote
well he's gonna suck well you didn't do
anything about it
only about half the voting age
population makes it to the polls and
groups including young people the poor
and the disabled are underrepresented on
voter rolls
do they not deserve a voice the act of
voting does not a good citizen make and
it's actually one of the least effective
ways you can contribute to the american
experiment
most social and cultural change happens
outside the political sphere
and that's a good thing rather than
follow the latest horse race you might
spend
your scarce time developing a new
vaccine exposing corruption
or microwaving a burrito any of these
things can have a greater tangible
impact on the world than your vote i
vote because it's all of our civic duty
people died for that right i vote
because i'm not a [ __ ]
communist
generations of brave americans have
fought for your right to vote
and for your right not to in fact you
might choose not to vote
because you love your country maybe you
don't feel educated or at least not
enough to cancel out the vote of your
well-informed neighbor
that's okay and really quite moral
besides
even the most knowledgeable voters can't
predict what a candidate will do once in
office
look a lot of our elected officials are
uninformed
remember when obama was going to reign
in w's foreign adventuring it was about
10 years and one drone kill list to go
they should just vote because it matters
you know
your employer can't tell you you don't
have time just get out and vote
a principled citizen might actively
avoid a two-party system that
systemically silences alternative voices
you might decide that it doesn't
represent your interests by design that
by voting for the lesser of two evils
you're only helping the fat cats in
washington maintain their smoke screen
of legitimacy
why on earth wouldn't you want to vote i
think voting is great i just didn't care
this time because it was between a giant
douche and a turd sandwich
but stan don't you know it's always
between a giant douche and a turd
sandwich
if that's the case you should feel free
to wash your hands the whole rotten mess
at the end of the day you might want to
vote maybe to give your granddaughter an
up close look at the machinery of
american government
maybe to get that fashion forward
sticker selfie that proves to all your
insta friends how woke or
uncut you are hi i'm fred i'm turning
out because i want to impress my friends
maybe you just really love middle school
gyms so this tuesday
go ahead and rock the vote if it makes
you happy but if you decide that it's a
symbolic gesture that's unlikely to
tangibly help your family or community
it's okay to spend your time and
resources doing something more impactful
this tuesday it's okay not to vote